[Music]
south-central baby there's no game and I
could teach you how to fight but
sometimes your best weapons are your
words you ever thought I get this close
to a vagina until I was at least 10 we
started this gym to keep kids off the
streets but doing good don't really pay
to bear then listen me and uncle Leon we
in here for bank robbery how much Wayne
million dollar the money's in the wall
in this flophouse in the basement what
has happened to the ghetto to a frat
house what are we gonna do I'm gonna get
him by joining the fraternity greetings
gentlemen I'm here to rush got a perfect
name to fit in the paternity sea shut
buttersworth
[Music]
your pledge master I'm about to see who
has what it takes white people they're
terrified of being caught races first
thing you slaves are gonna do an Ordnung
I'm not sure we should call the pledge
of slaves this year isn't it more racist
to change our tradition simply because
we got a black place I am so glad we're
finally having this discussion
uncle Lee y'all got my money yeah money
Oh nope I mean she do be liking my
pictures on Instagram late at night why
you guys weren't in Klan robes no our
fraternity actually predates the plan by
over a decade so why are they wearing
our robes yeah y'all wearing clear rows
all of that money an instant pantie
dropper
it's super confusing being a white male
in today's society okay hey black people
I ride the bus oh my god that was you
doing that is not what it looks like
looks like you got yourself caught up in
some races for ten people well then is
exactly what it looks like so I'm
charity galas coming up I'm gonna make
you the up snare now my great-great
great-great Grandaddy would love to hear
me say this get your bill folks out cuz
we by white people today
[Music]